[Musique]
ça recrute sur tv78 l'émission qui parle
emploi dans le département des ivelines
à chaque numéro son invité qui vient
parler de son secteur ou de son
entreprise qui embauche on vous donnera
également dans sa recrute quelques
conseils pour trouver un job ce soir
dans sa recrute notre invité et
Jean-Louis tison bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes le président du groupe
régional Île-de-France ouest de la Shen
la sen c'est la société française de
l'énergie nucléaire en quelques mots
c'est quoi la sphè alors ben merci tout
d'abord de de m'inviter à votre émission
merci d'être avec nous donc la shè c'est
une association loi 1901 qui a fêté son
50e anniversaire en 2023 elle est
composé de de 3000 membres actuellement
à peu près des des des des actifs du
nucléaire des retraités des enseignants
des des médecins et notre objectif c'est
de faire connaître nucléaire et si
possible de le faire avancer on va le
faire connaître ce secteur du nucléaire
dans cette émission puisqu'il y a
beaucoup de besoins avec les récentes
annonces concernant la la création de
nouveau réacteurs en France il faudrait
100000 embauches environ d'ici 2033
c'est-à-dire environ 10 à 15000
recrutements annuels sur les 10 ans à
venir alors justement avec vous Clara de
Frutos bonsoir de la rédaction tv78 on
va voir des offres d'emploi disponibles
directement sur le territoire dans le
secteur du nucléaire c'est ça j'ai
trouvé une offre d'emploi chez Talès
Veolia et Orano notamment et vous allez
nous les présenter tout à l'heure dans
sa
[Musique]
recrute alors une première question
Jean-Louis ton c'est même une deuxième
question puce qu'on a présenté laphen ça
représente quoi le secteur du nucléaire
dans les ivelines alors on peut même
parler dans votre zone globale Île de
France oest qui comprend les Yvelines le
valdoise et le nord des haut scèes alors
l'industrie nucléaire c'est d'abord
220000 emplois directs au niveau
national nous sommes la troème filière
industrielle après l'automobile et
l'aéronautique
alors le nucléaire c'est réparti sur
l'ensemble du territoire français c'est
pas uniquement concentré central c'est
pas uniquement concentré sur le lieu des
des centrales on fait du nucléaire un
petit peu partout en en support en
conception en en ingénierie alors pour
répondre à votre question sur l'ensemble
de l'île-de- France parmi les 220000
employés il y en a à peu près 47000 en
île-de-fance donc on peut parler d'un
secteur important enance absolument
absolument et pour aller plus dans le
détail pour répondre à votre question
nous avons fait une étude effectivement
pour notre secteur île-de-fance Ouest
département par département et au sein
des ivelines on a identifié à peu près
2000 emplois directs liés au au
nucléaire alors que nous n'avons aucun
centre de production aucune centrale
nucléaire dans notre territoire des
cvines mais il y a quand même de grosses
entreprises aussi des plus petites
entreprises il y a quand même pas mal
d'entreprises qui concernent le secteur
du nucléaire sur sur ce territoire des
yvelin absolument absolument alors je
peux vous donner quelques quelques
exemples nous avons par exemple les
installations suser à Bachelet dans les
ivelines fabriquant fabricant de pompe
l'essentiel de leur pompe fonctionne
dans les réacteurs et dans les centrales
nucléaires autre exemple comme fonction
support vous savez les travailleurs de
nucléaire ont un dosimètre en général
qui mesure leur leur exposition
mensuelle et bien ces dosimèes ces films
sont développés au visinet au sein de
l'Institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire par exemple l'IRSN vous
avez 150 emplois au vaisinés dédiés
complètement au au nucléaire et puis
vous avez bien sûr très proche d'ici à
Montini vous avez tout le transport
nucléaire chez Orano qui est organisé
depuis montigil le
Bretonneux quoi d'autre vous avez flower
les pompes il y a des des personnes qui
travaillent dans le dans le nucléaire à
ce niveau-là vous avez aussi dans le
secteur médical parce que le nucléaire
c'est pas uniquement l'électricité c'est
tout le secteur médical vous avez
général électrique à Buc qui emploie pas
mal de monde pour tous les appareils
médicaux d'irradiation et vous avez
agillancour une s siété qui prépare les
sources qui transportent les sources
radioactives qui sont utilisées pour les
traitements des des patients dans la la
médecine nucléaire donc beaucoup
d'entreprises et alors des grandes des
grandes et des petites petites de toute
taille Clara vous aviez une question
justement ou elles recrutent beaucoup
elles ont beaucoup de besoin du coup ces
entreprises alors les demandes
actuellement si vous voulez les 100000
emplois c'est pas spécialement les
100000 emplois nouveaux c'est pas
spécialement dans dans le côté de la la
la médecine c'est lié à à l'impulsion
qui est donnée au au nucléaire donc 6 pr
qui vont être construit d'ici 10 ans un
un PR c'est 8000 8000 emplois sur 10 ans
euh donc il faut il faut le construire
c'est aussi euh tout le prolongement de
la durée de vie des des centrales
nucléaires paraujourd'hui on a il y a 47
réacteurs qui sont disponibles en France
c'est ça ce matin sans doute oui à
l'heure où on parle on aimerait en on
aimerait en avoir encore plus parce que
aujourd'hui le le fuel et le charbon
tournent en France à leur capacité
maximum si on avait quelques réacteurs
de plus on nurait pas de de foule de
charbon ou de gaz aujourd'hui et vous
parliez alors de cette étude que vous
avez mené en interne qu'est-ce qu'elle
nous apprend sur l'emploi dans notre
région et aussi une chose importante à
préciser on parlait de ces métiers c'est
il y a aussi une diversité de métiers
aussi bien des métiers d'ingénieur que
des postes plus industriels dans dans
nucléaire alors dans dans le nucléaire
on a tous les types de postees bon c'est
un fondement technique hein bien sûr au
départ il y a toutes les fonctions
support associées mais on recrute dans
dans tous les les domaines on a besoin
de tous les domaines juste en deux mots
un un réacteur c'est de l'eau qui
circule à très haute pression 150 barres
à 300°gr donc ce sont des conduites
métalliques très important
c'est un une turbine une centrale
nucléaire c'est une turbine qui tourne
de 1500 tours par minute plusieurs
centaines de tonnes donc il faut faire
tourner tout cet ensemble et quand je
vous dis de l'eau à haute température à
à haute pression ben c'est du métal
c'est le confinement c'est de l'acier ce
sont des métiers liés à la métallurgie
essentiellement dans les réacteurs
nucléaire et donc quelles sont les
compétences pour pour travailler dans le
secteur du nucléaire
alors je je je j'aurais du mal à vous
qualifier mais par exemple si je prends
l'exemple du du métal mais on a besoin
de de chaudronnier de soudeur de
charpentier métallique toutes les
fonctions ce sont des c'est une fonction
de le nucléaire où on n'est pas au
contact directement de la matière du
nucléaire donc c'est de la télécommande
c'est de la robotique c'est du de
l'automatisme tout tous les équipements
moderne nouveau on en a on en a besoin
dans le le nucléaire on a compris qu'il
allait avoir des besoins grandissants
est-ce que quand même aujourd'hui les
entreprises liées au secteur du
nucléaire ont du mal à trouver leur
candidat et si oui comment on peut
l'expliquer alors alors alors
oui oui nous avons du mal à recruter à
trouver nos des personnes qualifiées
alors
pourquoi d'abord ben n nos écoles
d'ingénieurs forment des ingénieurs mais
souvent nos ingénieurs dans les années
passées sont pas allés faire de la
technique ils sont allés faire de la de
la finance ou de ou de l'économie donc
il y a eu il y a eu un gap et puis il y
a une période où on n pas construit de
nouveaux réacteurs donc les besoins
étaient pas aussi bien
identifiés rentrer dans le nucléaire
pour démanteler une centrale toute sa
toute sa vie c'est pas moteur et donc ça
on a eu un problème de de recrutement
dans le secteur du nucléaire mais
aujourd'hui on part avec un nouvel élan
pour plusieurs décennies plusieurs
centaines d'années j'espère et donc
est-ce que il y a une voie royale pour
rentrer dans ce métier alors alors la
voie royale je dirais euh devant ce
manque que vous avez identifié on a mis
en place un un un trois piliers le le
premier pilier c'est pour indiquer la
voie royale c'est une une plateforme
numérique c'est mon avenir dans le
nucléaire sans sans tréma sans lien mon
avenir dans le nucléaire c'est une
plateforme qui identifie toutes les les
formations qu'on peut qu'on peut avoir
et tous les métiers qui sont qui sont
proposés actuellement vous avez une
offre de 4500 emplois sur la plateforme
mon avenir dans nucléaire ce qui est
distingué en fonction de la
qualification de départ cap avant le bac
après le bac doctorat nous avons toute
une palette complète de métiers qui sont
proposés dans le nucléaire quelquesunes
de C seront d'ailleurs présenté par
Clara absolument il y a aussi une
université des métiers alors alors
l'Université des métiers du nucléaire
qui a été créée en
2021 rapproche les les besoins de
l'industrie et les offres de formation
il faut qu'il y ait un match entre les
l'éducation la qualification qui est
acquise dans le l'université et l'offre
d'emploi et besoin on dit souvent qu'il
a du mal à faire matcher demandeur
d'emploi et
recruteurs on s'y attache de plus en
plus sur les métiers spécifiques du du
nucléaire et pour les faire connaître il
y a une semaine d'ailleurs qui est
dédiée qui aura lieu en février je
précise juste les dates c'est du 5 au 9
février 2e édition de la la semaine des
métiers du nucléaire absolument 2è
édition alors c'est une semaine au
niveau national où on aura des
événements sur l'ensemble du territoire
on a prévu 125 je crois autour un plus
de 100 événements consacrés à la semaine
des métiers de nucléaire pour montrer ce
que l'on fait dans le nucléaire attirer
aussi des des candidats alors trois
offres d'emploi à suivre avec du concret
avec vous Clara sur ces métiers du
nucléaire juste avant le conseil de
France travail ex Pôle emploi pour être
embauché ce sera récurrent dans sa
recrute et ce soir c'est un conseil qui
concerne le fameux CV le conseil que je
donne aujourd'hui à à au aux demandeurs
d'emplo fois qui sont en recherche
active c'est de d'adapter leur CV au
poste qui est diffusé à l'offre d'emploi
aussi et le rendre vraiment percutant et
le rendre
attirant tout en faisant attention à ce
qu'il ait pas trop d'information inutile
dessus mettre en avant ses
compétences professionnelles son savoir
son savoir faire et son savoir-être
aussi donc la le conseil que je donne
aux chercheurs d'emploi c'est vraiment
de les mettre en avant euh sur un CV
percutant sans oublier la bandeannonce
la phrase d'accroche la phrase
d'accroche qui va être là pour donner un
petit aperçu global de la personnalité
de ce que peut offrir le candidat à à
l'employeur pour pouvoir se démarquer et
pouvoir se se différencier des autres il
faut avoir un CV qui soit percutant et
on termine avec vous Clara trois offres
d'emploi dans le secteur du nucléaire on
commence avec une première offre chez
Thalès c'est ça l'entreprise basée à
ellancour propose un poste de leader
technique en CDI alors pour ce poste vos
principales missions seront de piloter
et orienter une équipe pour définir
l'architecture d'un réacteur nucléaire
définir et formaliser des spécifications
au niveau du système déterminer des
exigences et identifier et garantir des
choix techniques pour ce qui est des
compétences vous devrez maîtriser les
méthodes d'ingénierie système et
d'architecture fonctionnelle et physique
avoir une expérience dans la
modélisation système savoir piloter des
infrastructures de grande taille et
complexe et avoir une bonne culture
scientifique technique et un bon niveau
d'anglais une formation d'ingénieur est
demandée et une expérience d'au moins 15
ans dans l'architecture et le
développement de système très complexe
est aussi exigé et pour le salaire rien
n'est spécifié une deuxième offre
d'emploi vous nous emmenez à à Limet
c'est ça le groupe Veolia recherche un
nouveau technicien recherche et
développement en procédés de traitement
de déchets en CDI les principales
missions seront de participer à la
réalisation d'essaiis de traitement de
déchets à l'échelle laboratoire ou
pilote participer à l'entretien et la
maintenance des installations contribuer
à l'amélioration des installations en
terme de sécurité et de performance et
quelles sont les compétences il est
demandé d'avoir un bon sens de
l'orientation une bonne capacité à
travailler en équipe et à communiquer et
d'être R rigoureux une formation de bac+
2 ou Bac + 3 spécialité procédé ou chéie
est également préconisée vous devez
aussi avoir minimum 5 ans d'expérience
en tant que technicien supérieur et
encore une fois pour le salaire aucune
fourchette n'est indiquée la dernière
offre d'emploi vous nous emmené à montig
bretonau on parlait du groupe Orano tout
à l'heure avec janlouis Tizon oui Orano
cherche un nouvel ingénieur sûreté en
industrie du nucléaire en CDI pour pour
ce poste vous serez amené à réaliser
vérifier et encadrer des prestation de
calcul de radioprotection vous devrez
aussi réceptionner et analyser des
données proposer des calculs et des
études de sensibilité pour répondre aux
besoins de cette analyse de sûreté et
développer des outils informatiques pour
améliorer et optimiser la performance de
ces études et en ce qui concerne les
compétences justement et ben vous devrez
avoir une capacité d'analyse et de
synthèse de synthèse assez poussé vous
devez savoir travailler en équipe avoir
des connaissances en calcul
radioprotection et en programmation
informatique et surtout aussi encore une
fois avoir un bon niveau d'anglais une
formation d'ingénieur bac + 5 avec une
spécialisation dans le domaine de la
radiprotection d'interaction rayonnement
matière ou génie du nucléaire est
demandé vous devez aussi disposer d'une
expérience significative d'au moins 10
ans en calcul de radioprotection et une
fois encore pour le salaire rien n'est
indiqué sur l'offre al on peut rien
indiquer en terme de salaire ce qu'on
bien sa vie quand on travaille dans le
nucléaire alors le d'abord effectivement
2 tiers des des employés sont soit
cadres soit étam
employés technicien agent de maîtrise
donc c'est déjà une qualification élevée
pour les 2/ers du personnel et
effectivement ce qui a été observé par
exemple sur autour d'une centrale
nucléaire c'est que la population autour
les employés d'une centrale nucléaire
sont
plutôt bien payé et apporte du pouvoir
d'achat sur la sur la région et il crée
en général plus d'emplois induits près
d'une centrale nucléaire du fait de leur
pouvoir d'achat alors toutes les offres
d'emplois dont tu as parlé Clara bien
d'autres encore sont à retrouver sur
différents sites on parle avec vous de
mon avenir dans le nucléaire.fr
toutattaché.fr il y a aussi des offres
sur le portail indide à 50 ans en ni il
également le portail
skiemploi.fr qui vous donne la
possibilité de trouver des offres
d'emploi près de chez vous un
rendez-vous avant de refermer ce numéro
de sa recrute c'est le retour du salon
de étudiants en iveline c'est le samedi
20 janvier au Vélodrome national de 50
ans en Yveline de 10h à 18h sur place
vous retrouverez plein d'exposants qui
vous ont qui vous aideront à y voir plus
clair dans vos projets d'orientation et
pourquoi pas dans la filière nucléaire
vous pouvez préparer votre visite en
vous inscrivant sur le site
l'Étudiant.fr voilà c'est la fin de ce
numéro de sa recrute merci de votre
fidélité Merci à VOUS
Jean-Louis président du groupe régional
î France Ouest de la sen la société
française de l'énergie nucléaire merci
également à Clara de Frutos de m'avoir
accompagné une nouvelle fois sur cette
émission et on se retrouve dans de
semaines pour un nouveau numéro de sa
recrute sur tv78 belle soirée à
[Musique]
tous